en france l'action de la police est à
nouveau critiqué à montreuil près de
paris
hier soir une manifestation a de nouveau
tourné à l'affrontement avec les forces
de l'ordre une manifestation qui visait
à soutenir un homme de 34 ans qui a
perdu un oeil
on l'évoqué tiers il aurait été victime
d'un tir de flash-ball arnault compte
jean-marc nouknouk ils protestaient
contre ce qu'ils appellent des violences
policières contre un tir de flash ball
qui auraient grièvement blessé à l'oeil
un homme de 34 ans hier soir le
rassemblement a dégénéré visés par des
projectiles les policiers chargent un
groupe de manifestants
une intervention de trop pour la maire
de la ville
je suis extrêmement déçu de ce qui s'est
passé hier parce que je constate que
c'est toujours les habitudes de cow boy
qui prévalent on l'a vu avec l' usage du
flash-ball mercredi on l'a vu avec l'
usage de matraques hier mercredi dernier
joachim gatti petit-fils d'un dramaturge
et membre d'un mouvement autonome
protestent contre l'évacuation de ce
squat
selon plusieurs témoignages il aurait
été touché en plein visage par une balle
de flashball café peuvent en témoigner
ils ont vu se déployer une quinzaine de
policiers qui ont tiré sur les gens qui
étaient là sans sommation
jeudi ils ont visé à la tête parce que
mon fils arthur flashball dans l'oeil et
toutes les personnes qui ont été
touchées ont été touchés sur les épaules
ou sur le thorax
la police des polices a ouvert une
enquête et ce n'est pas la première
en mai dernier à villiers-le-bel deux
hommes montrent eux aussi perdu un oeil
après des affrontements avec la police
en mars à toulouse un étudiant est
blessé au visage en marge d'une
manifestation
le flash-ball utilisés par la police le
voici une arme de 4e catégorie comme un
fusil à pompe
ces munitions des balles de caoutchouc
conçu pour ne pas tuer une arme parfois
difficiles à maîtriser selon les
policiers il y a aucune notion de
précisions quant à l'utilisation du
flash-ball est une arme qui est très peu
précise qui ne fait que pour repousser
des personnes qui vous agressent dans le
cas de légitime défense
récemment la direction de la police
nationale a envoyé une circulaire à ses
hommes elle leur rappelle qu'ils doivent
faire un usage proportionné du flash
ball et ne pas viser la tête
[Musique]